non est ce qu'ils en font trop sur
carlos ghosn vous dites non raymond
étudiants sinon puisqu'ils cette
histoire elle fascine à l'histoire est
facilement qui s'ébattent dans une malle
tout ça je m'en fous pour moi c'est de
la mascarade il a eu des sous il avait
réussi à faire marcher ses réseaux tant
mieux il est parti à beyrouth après il
va revenir en france tranquillement il
en faut pas trop faux nous informez moi
j'ai envie d'être à former parce qu'ici
soirée folle
maintenant elle a décidé de fuir le
japon parce qu'il pense que là bas il
est maltraité qui est il a découvert la
prison malgré que le japon sont un pays
démocratique il préfère se sauver j'aime
pas l'idée de sauver mois mais lui il a
décidé de se sauver
si maintenant je veux que ça aille
jusqu'au bout et surtout moi ce que j'ai
envie dans cette histoire j'ai envie
qu'ils balancent des mecs j'ai envie
qu'ils racontent pourquoi ils en il en
arriver là prête foi parce que si c'est
pour me dire bah je suis matin je me
suis sauvé je suis en france qu'il en
sait très bien
sinon je suis extra dre julie pradet et
dans deux semaines on va avoir un débat
ici faut-il faut-il aller voir le film
de carlos ghosn ça marche pas comme ça
moi j'aimerais qu'il dise les choses
fut-ce que de tout l'homme au bras me
cas plus que des millions puis changes
depuis tout son bon vieux monde
s'intéresse pas plus que ça
c'est hallucinant intéressant qu'il dise
la vérité d'années encore je ne fais pas
condamné voilà quand même un homme iv
avec qui pour l'instant a fui la justice
du pays dans lequel il était malgré tout
coop a condamné mme en tous les cas
présentent ou alors mis en cause dans ce
pays là il a fui et puis maintenant
alors c'est un show il a fait un show de
deux heures
il les a montrés d d d d d des trucs
dans tous les sens avec des chiffres les
comprenais rien les journalistes étaient
comme des petits garçons trop content de
tendre le micro du tour et dont on
écoutait ce qu'ils nous disaient c'est
alors un héros y en a
c'était énormément critiqué c'est léa
salamé rire voilà elle avait l'air trop
contente à l'idée d'interroger carlos
ghosn et elle s'est fait la peau des
fois c'est sûr les réseaux regard des
prévisions facile absolument
le monde entier pour beaucoup d'enfants
vous êtes l'homme qui a voyagé dans la
malle mais vous savez vraiment voyager
dans la malle ça vaut moins de vendée
trop je vous dis je n'en parlerai pas je
prends mon temps des photos de ma d'une
malle trou et l'aurait fait défaut ces
défauts sont auto alors attendez on a
mal pas la malle allez un petit indice
tout le monde rêve de savoir ça oui mais
enfin au contraire il faut maintenir le
suspense il faut que les gens continuent
de ses amis me disent que je ne dis pas
que c'est faux là bas alors suspense et
mcqueen dans la grande et vernet faut
maintenir le suspens faute de quoi on
parle
vous savez ça sera une série bientôt sur
des fuites dans deux ans c'est
hallucinant jean michel meunier à vous
retirer l'histoire de la malle serait
parti avec un jet privé comme tout le
monde pas comme tous les gens qui sont
puissants et c'est ça repart fait un tel
buzz là les seules questions qui
reviennent et c'est le seul domaine elle
a mal ne pas parler ses sorties il y
avait des trous comme il l'a montré que
c'est pas vrai c'est sa fille jean est
faux mais alors là ça là mais je peux
pas la laisser en l'état tant s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît grâce à l'arrêt
moque espère voir même en voiture je
peux pas voir je n'allais les plantes et
dire est allé gentil mais c'est mon avis
et je donne mon avis sauf que là il ya
des soirs de la malle qui fait le buzz
c'est vrai ya pas d en vous comprenez
qu'elle soit fait défoncer saison les
rushes et zaoui pascal a dit des bêtises
la max et ses enfants elle assure
l'auteur parce que les gens nous
rejoignent sur twitter amis sur les
réseaux ce qui regarde et léa salamé
devant l'héroïsme de carlos ghosn
voilà léa salamé regarder voilà en
casimir l'enquète de léa salamé en
avance bien
carlos ghosn vu par léa salamé voilà
regarder la défense d'uribe ont fait pas
table j'ai passé après a racheté ses
relais des gens et moi je sais ce que
j'ai d'abord j'aime pas les arabes et ça
je le dis sauf que sauf que elle a fait
son histoire de mal à ça devant ça veut
rien dire si ça l'a fait rire que l sauf
que la poser toutes les questions en
voilà que je voulais qu'elle pose à se
joindre au combat
j'aime pas l'histoire de la malle et
j'aime pas qui a souri trop elle sourit
trop ça mais la cfa travail sain mais
qui sait valais il doit être pays doit
être jugé il doit être jugé et elle
sourit devant un mec qui s'évade comme
si c'était voilà des choses que
l'arrivée son travail poser la question
c'est bien c'est un scoop que tout le
monde voulait avoir tous les
journalistes voir carlos ghosn elle a
réussi à l'avoir elle veut pas elle a du
mal à masquer son plaisir d'avoir dit à
tout le monde à la barbe de tout le
monde c'est moi qui l'ait il ya une
question sur lesquels tout le monde lui
est tombé dessus parce qu'il fallait
bien trouver une porte d'entrée pour lui
tomber dessus c'était l'histoire de la
malle mais là effectivement poser toutes
les questions que tout le monde se
posait et je trouve que vous êtes
particulièrement choqué parce que c'est
un c'est un sujet qui intéresse mais oui
tout le monde c'est c'est une histoire
politico judiciaire me donnent tous les
ingrédients sont là voilà bien je suis
restée relève moi ça me fascine
wellwood la justice là bas il ya un
ministère de la justice ici il ya de la
politique il ya de l'évasion il ya tout
simplement ne va pas réagir sur tous les
sujets mme legras toi ce soir donc
plusieurs ont terminé deux secondes je
le veux dire aussi c'est qui et on s'est
tapé deux heures d'interviews qu'il est
indigeste qui répond on entend les pas
des questions escapade micro les
questions étaient parfois des réponses
et parfois en anglais en français on
comprenait on comprenait pas et puis
excuse moi le matin même d'un érable et
frappé les l'irak 34 amassé assez un peu
plus savoir l' escalade qui aurait une
guerre entre les etats-unis et l'iran ça
n'a pas d'intérêt
isabelle parce que je prends des ja du
romanesque
tous n'ont pas dit non mais on est
obligé de céder finalement du fait qui a
procédé à quelque chose d'intéressant à
dire on fait un faux procès à la salle
abbé dehors d'une grande journaliste
la seule chose c'est qu'on lui reproche
d'avoir fait d'avoir agiter ses réseaux
parce qu'il faut quand même rappeler que
c'est comme la fille oui un ministre de
la culture libanais évidemment pour lui
un peu rapproché à huy cette information
voilà c'est un jour amené le personnage
de carlos ghosn justement à france inter
ça c'est une info que j'avais pas bravo
fab lab à voir si on pense les gens
tiens voilà ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît le
sondage rapidement oui 63 % non à 37% du
bourg et bien sûr tous horizons plus tôt
voilà de votre côté